an absolutely heartbreaking story out of
Sayreville New Jersey tonight where a 30
year old city council member Eunice
gemfor was shot and killed and what
appears to be a targeted attack just
outside of her home Fox News
correspondent Nate Foy has all the
details Nate
yeah Lord just an absolutely tragic
story New Jersey councilwoman Eunice 1-4
was a 30 year old mother of a young
daughter she was very involved in her
church yet according to multiple reports
she was targeted in this shooting while
driving near her home and she wasn't
shot by one stray bullet she was shot
multiple times police found her dead
when they arrived at the crime scene
drum 4 was the chair of sayreville's
Public Safety Committee and she worked
very closely with the new police chief
to reduce crime but sayreville's
business administrator says he doesn't
think that played a role in her murder I
can't think of anything that she could
have done or said that would have made
her a target of such a heinous act
nothing that would uh lead us to believe
it had any her her role in the public
safety uh Community had nothing to do
with this horrifying incident Laura this
is the neighborhood where dorm 4 was
murdered police tell us this is very
unusual here it's not the type of place
where you would expect something like
this to happen sarahville's mayor
released a statement writing in part
quote as a community we are shocked and
saddened at the loss of Eunice 1-4
Eunice was a dedicated member of our
Borough Council who was truly committed
to serve all of our residents the fact
that she was taken from us by a
Despicable criminal act makes this
incident all the more horrifying New
Jersey governor Phil Murphy is promising
State support throughout this
investigation Laura
Nate thank you joining me now is Pastor
nelia Rodriguez she was friends with the
councilwoman and last year saw her
yesterday and last saw her yesterday
morning Pastor thank you for joining us
this is such a tragic story we're so
sorry for your loss now you say that
this killing was very personal
what what do you mean by that
um we believe it's very personal because
she was shot seven times in the face and
another seven shot were hidden
everywhere so for somebody to get so
close to somebody and shoot them so many
times it has to be personal
do you have any sense that this could be
some type of hate crime religiously
motivated given the uh religious
violence that's happening in Nigeria
some say that this violence could be
brought I mean from Ghana could be
brought to the United States
um is that possible
anything possible uh just because what's
going on like what we had in problem
with Bloomfield and everything that's
going on with all the inner phrases it
could be possible but at this point we
don't have any answers to that question
but it's a possibility
well for someone to be shot seven times
at close range
in the face I mean it's cartel or it's
something personal now in addition to
being a councilwoman Eunice was also an
active member of her church and here she
is preaching just a few years ago
the beautiful thing about God almighty
God almighty is like a diamond
he has many sides to him
the way I may relate with God Almighty
is different from how you relate with
him that is the beauty of God
uh Pastor your reaction she was she was
an amazing person and that was at her
church which is a Nigerian Church
um by all accounts an amazing woman an
incredible asset to the community why
would someone do this
there's there's probably not an answer
why would somebody do that somebody who
has no heart somebody who has no love
for Community who somebody who could
have been jealous it could have been
many reasons why somebody would hurt
somebody like her who was such a
beautiful soul Who Loved everybody who
always smiled she'd never said no she
would take her jacket off to give it to
you her soul was so beautiful she was
such a light to everybody in the
community that is horrifying to even
think of anybody trying to hurt her
Pastor have the police said they have
any leads any security camera footage
from anyone
there's hasn't been at least the only
thing that they they have comment is
that
um there was a man standing next to the
car and then he ran into the woods
that's the only thing that has been said
there's nothing else that we could uh go
buy these at this point well we're going
to follow up on this uh pastor we are so
sorry for your loss this is just a
heartbreaker um thank you for joining us
and telling her story hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else